this may not look like an important
piece of medical equipment
but it could be one of the critical
things keeping covid19 patients alive
it's an emergency ventilator designed by
a team from mit
that is trying to use common equipment
both medical
we want to use one of these emboo bag
things
to ventilate people and automotive
windshield wiper motors
are one of the most engineered things on
the planet
fda approved ventilators are
sophisticated machines that cost roughly
thirty thousand dollars and require
hundreds of components
the mit team took that as a challenge
design a low-cost ventilator that could
be built
anywhere there's need they put their
research on an open source website so
that
groups around the world adapt it to what
they had locally and give feedback
we spoke with research scientist nevin
hanumara and professors
alex slocum and daniela roos the idea
that we could
attach a robotic device that is easy to
manufacture
low cost robust and gentle to the bag
is what guided our work the design
can be broken up into three main parts
the breathing circuit
the mechanical ventilator and the
controls
the breathing circuit is made up of
supplies that hospitals already have on
hand
we refer to it as the manual
resuscitator bag
the breathing circuit and the
endotracheal tube
the heart of the design is the ambu bag
a very common piece of equipment in
hospitals
it's a manual respirator usually
squeezed by trained
medical personnel to push air into the
lungs of patients temporarily
you can't have one responder
per patient squeezing one of these
ambu bag things to ventilate people
so we need a little box to do that
automatically
ambu bags are common life-saving
equipment but they aren't designed for
long-term use
keeping the bag from wearing out too
quickly was the first challenge
the team needed to be able to use them
for weeks just like the electrically
powered ventilators usually used by
hospitals
the general theme is be nice to your bag
because if this thing that's normally
meant to just be squished for an hour
has to do for two weeks you don't want
to break it
to do that they had to build a pair of
gentle yet robust robotic hands
that curved shape of the hands or the
paddles
it gives us that nice gentle rolling to
keep the center of the bag
happy originally the idea was to have a
design that could be created
in maker spaces around the world but
they soon discovered the machines would
need far more industrial materials if
they were going to keep covid19 patients
breathing
their first prototype used laser-cut
plastic for the hands
that plastic is fine for hobby projects
but it quickly failed when tested
this makerspace laser-cut plastic is no
good you need to design this thing so
you could kick it across the room
the solution they reinforced the hands
with metal
strengthening the robotic hands was an
easy design fix
now there was a new problem the
increased load on the machine's gears
and motors
their first design relies on a single
motor turning two gears
the gears engage each other so if you
move one hand the other hand will be
forced to go with it
and it works great it's a fine thing but
the gears
are highly stressed when you get to
these big loads of the covet patients
to fix this problem the team is
exploring a new idea
using two motors to control the two
hands separately
they found a possible solution in an
unlikely place
the front of nearly every car on earth
we're using windshield wiper motor
one of the most engineered things on the
planet i mean they're designed to go
well you know what they do they can beat
the tar out of them
it's easier in places around the world
to grab two wiper motors
because the ones we're using are nearly
ubiquitous then to require
relatively good manufacturing to get the
gear design to work
however as the designs continue to
evolve the control aspect of the machine
becomes more and more important if you
have two motors
now the software has to ensure that the
two motors
are well synchronized because otherwise
if one
one arm pushes and the other one forgets
to come in to help
you don't really have a working system
after consulting with doctors
a few necessary requirements became
clear
one of the reasons ventilators work is
because they give healthcare workers
fine control
over the volume of air pushed into the
lungs how many breaths
per minute and the ratio of inhale to
exhale
so the team built a control board that
works like a retro stereo with big
turnable knobs even though in a very
simple design what what's the minimum
information we need so that someone is
respiratory trained
can make the necessary adjustments they
also had to include
critical alarms that would go off if the
pressure in the lungs was too much
or too little the doctor doesn't care
about the guts of the machine the doctor
just wants to adjust the knob and then
so that's where you have this balance
between
mechanical complexity and control
complexity
recently the team consulted with 10x
beta in new york to create
three thousand ventilators called the
spirowave and many teams around the
world are building
similar prototypes as covid19 spreads
the team wants to make sure that this
design can be used in local supply
chains
especially where it might be difficult
to access normal ventilators
the website provides an interface for
people to leave feedback
and learn about what could work for
their own markets there's many different
mechanisms you can envision as people
are
and will the things that are the same
will be the forces
uh the alarms that are needed these
functional requirements
and then now it's up to the creative
people which they're all over the place
and then they can apply it to what they
do have for local production
[Music]